hey youtubers its charlie thank you
everybody that's many questions on my
Walking Dead videos just in case you
didn't see on Monday I was talking a
little bit about the ratings what
actually went down after the premiere so
it turned out a little over 10 million
people just in the US watched fear The
Walking Dead episode 1 that doesn't
include international people typically
when ratings are reported for shows that
are in the United States they're just
talking about United States ratings some
of you guys said you had a hard time
finding it just because internationally
it airs on a bunch of different
television stations show can be a little
confusing but it sounds like a couple
days later as of like right now most of
you have found one way or another to
watch it it'll probably take a few weeks
to figure out but there's only six
episodes and they will do reruns when
the main show comes back on like though
they'll keep showing these six episodes
throughout the season and they've
already confirmed a 15 episode season
two they Crean lit it like a long time
ago actually so just in terms of
popularity about eight million people
watch the season five premiere of Game
of Thrones but you have to I mean you to
remember its premium cable so the
numbers a little wonky with that a
little over ten million watched this
episode of fear The Walking Dead and
then just a little over 17 million
people watched season 5 episode 1 of The
Walking Dead of the main show just for
comparison whenever the main show first
premiered its ratings were way lower
than fear the walking dead but the
fandom has grown so like this is a very
different TV landscape but in terms of
popularity it crushed so I don't think
they're gonna be any issues with fear
The Walking Dead being a really popular
show that being said most shows aren't
like the best they're ever gonna be the
minute they premiere it takes the
writers a little while to settle in but
let's get to questions so here we go
killer plays s it'd be cool if we saw
characters who are dead in the Walking
Dead and see them before all [ __ ] broke
loose there are gonna be a ton more
flashbacks
they didn't say which characters would
be flashing back but like we saw a
Michonne we saw Rick flashbacks last
year they'll just continue to be a lot
more stuff probably some Morgan
flashbacks - next question
outsider asks I'd love to see Clementine
in a future season that cameo would make
the internet explode well I don't know
Tibet explode but I'm actually I'm not
expecting to see Clementine on the main
show that there's an issue of
intellectual property
AMC would actually have to pay money to
telltale to use that character it's a
really weird situation with licensed
shows like that it's the same thing with
game
Thrones telltale game I'm just I'm not
expecting to see any of those characters
cross over but they might reference some
of the things that happen in the game
offhandedly is it's easier to get away
with stuff like that or like casual
turns of phrase when you refer to
something else without stepping on
anyone's legal toes it's really weird
but you can get sued for looking at
someone the wrong way out in Hollywood
next question Nico asks I wonder if
Morgan is the replacement character for
Jesus in the comics even if you don't
understand who Jesus is in the comics I
can say no Morgan isn't a replacement
for anyone Morgan is actually in the
comics in this place in Alexandria in
the safe zone his storyline is just like
a little bit different like the reason
that he gets to the Alexandria safe zone
but he is a character in this storyline
where they're at right now if they don't
end up actually doing the Jesus
character they could kind of spread some
of his storyline in the comics to a
couple other characters sometimes
they'll do that will they'll give
storylines like Andrea's storyline in
the comics is kind of what Sasha is
doing on the show right now
next question Billy Chang asks who do
you think will die this season well
there's there's always a certain amount
of red shirts that they killed just to
say oh hey we're back you know this is a
new season people die all the time and
then there are the like the rugs that
they try to pull out like people that
make you feel safe that they want to get
rid of from a writer standpoint like the
way Gimple explains it is that when
characters feel like too much of a
safety net for the survivors that's when
they try to take that away the best
example is Hershel like Hershel was a
really wise person gave really great
advice made everyone feel a little bit
safer even though he himself wasn't
super powerful and Gimple said that well
we really just wanted to take that
safety net away from them so anybody who
makes you feel super safe or feel semi
invincible they're probably gonna be the
next ones to die that's why you see a
lot of the main characters like Daryl be
super flawed if Daryl for whatever
reason suddenly turned into a genius
then I would get worried about him but
as long as he still seems like an
outdoor cat that thinks he's an indoor
cat he's completely safe next question
Riki Cortes s love fear The Walking Dead
sucks that it's only six episodes though
well like I mentioned earlier there's
gonna be 15 episodes in season 2 and
thereafter
each season that it gets renewed it'll
just probably get like another 15 or 16
episodes
I have no idea why it's 15 episodes
instead of 16 but they might stagger the
dates that it airs on with the main show
the other option would be for them to
air it like an hour before the main show
or they could air it even later at night
but I don't know that they want to do
that next question Liana start gasps
can't say it felt as intense when I
first watched The Walking Dead Season
one Episode one but I was hooked yeah a
lot of people are gonna kind of that
feeling where it's like not quite as
intense as you remember the Walking Dead
being but you have to remember that now
that we understand the threat of the
walkers it's like a completely different
sense of suspense it really does change
the way you watch a show when you know
what's going to happen when you know the
end point when they were promoting the
show they did say they were thinking
about that they're like oh it's gonna be
fun for the audience because they know
what's coming I don't know that that's
why it's fun to watch the show really in
order for me to enjoy a show I have to
get invested in the characters and it's
probably gonna take a couple episodes
before like I really settle in on my
favorites
I like Travis's character I think he's
gonna be a good protagonist cliff Curtis
is just an amazing actor I think I've
already said like a billion times how
much I like Kim Dickens I'm not quite
feeling the younger characters yet but I
think in the next couple of episodes
we'll see some of them come into their
own as [ __ ] starts to go crazy I know
some of you were talking about the
female actress the daughter actress is
from the 100 and she's a pretty big
badass on that show so I'm looking
forward to her doing some really crazy
stuff next question Mike gasps this is
actually a trailer question from the the
main show I think when Rick is saying do
you have any idea who you're talking to
and saying you think you can take this
place for me he's talking to the leader
of the Wolves maybe that they got in
invaded and just got ruined by the
survivors so yeah that it's totally
possible I mean they mess with our heads
when they post the trailers thinking
that Rick is talking to someone else
Gimple actually said something really
interesting about the firm a be the
first or second episode he said early in
the season I'm assuming he was talking
about the first episode but the giant
maker heard that's slowly moving towards
them the survivors are gonna use them to
solve some of their big problems in a
really roundabout way that's all he said
he just kind of teased that so what
might end up happening is is like the
Wolves move on with their trucks like
they bring in their W walkers but the
survivors find a way
to use the super herd to take out the
wolves herd either way I think we're
gonna see some crazy super herd action
in that first episode next question Marv
asks being said in LA I'd love to see
some celebrity cameos in which
celebrities play themselves yeah you
mean like you like heightened versions
of themselves driving along and then
they get pulled out of the car by a
walker I'm not expecting too many just
because it's really expensive to get
celebrity cameos but they do film in LA
so I wouldn't be surprised as they were
like one or two minor cameos usually
when I hear about celebrities going on
walking dead it's it's like the
producers of the show saying hey come on
we'll turn you into a walker we'll put
you in makeup no one will recognize you
it's a little bit different with fear
The Walking Dead zombies because they
have so much of their skin intact you'd
actually would be able to recognize them
next question t-man XS did the mom get
bit cuz it looked like she did well they
wanted you to think she did but I kind
of got it ruined for me because I
understand what a big actress Kim
Dickens is so like in my my brain where
I analyze shows I'm thinking well
they're not gonna kill the main actor of
the show she's gonna be in all six
episodes that can happen sometimes when
you start watching too much TV where
you're like okay this is clearly like a
special guest actor he might be around
for one or two episodes but that's it
the best example against that like where
they present someone as the main star
but then they kill him off anyway would
be Sean Bean from Game of Thrones that's
why when they did that during Game of
Thrones Season 1 everyone went so crazy
because they're like oh my god they
killed the main star fear the walking
dead I think is gonna be a little more
traditional so I'm expecting all those
family like most of the family members
that we met in the episode to survive to
season 2
notice that I said most of them I'm not
expecting everybody to make it to season
2 next question Christina asked I only
watch the episode once so I don't know
the names too well but do you think the
daughter's boyfriend who didn't show up
at Venice Beach is a walker yeah yeah
the boyfriend that just she couldn't
find at the end I do think that he is
marked for death but I think that he'll
like he'll surprise us and show up in
the second episode it just feels like
that party at his parents house but you
know when they're out of town feels too
good for a crazy Walker attack but that
could always be a misdirect like she
could go looking for him and find him as
a walker at his house
next question Seth asks is Nick patient
zero
so I actually I saw a lot of questions
this like is this the beginning of the
outbreak does that mean we're seeing the
first instances of zombies or I should
say walkers no that is actually not the
case
remember what Tobias was talking about
Tobias was the chubby kid that got his
knife taken away the Kim Dickens was
talking to Madison's character he was
talking about outbreaks in five states
and people not understanding whether or
not there was a virus going around so it
sounds like the outbreak had already
started in his initial stages people
were slowly turning but it hadn't turned
into a large-scale thing like it hadn't
been caught on camera yet so in terms of
the timeline I'm guessing patient zero
was maybe like a week or two or a couple
weeks before what we're seeing happen
right now Robert Kirkman's always been
really hardcore about not over
explaining how the virus started where
it came from how it spread so fast but
you can you can start guessing like they
kept talking about the flu shot that
probably helped widespread immunization
then you have good old-fashioned human
contact but but the outbreak spreads
exponentially so it starts really slow
like it takes a while and then it just
goes crazy by the time it spreads across
the United States and the rest of the
world but thank you so much everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do it'll be interesting to see
how far they take these first six
episodes I'm expecting by the end of
episode six then la will be just being
like a complete trash heap what I'm
gonna do is just like for the main show
each week I'll do my review video where
I'll do like my top five top ten moments
then I'll do the QA the next day I'll
off to try and balance it with the Game
of Thrones videos but it should all work
out just fine congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner grant Doherty you
win a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact info
if you haven't been watching it - vixen
the animated CW spinoff from the flash
and arrow just aired so you guys should
check it out it's only five minutes but
it's also gonna be six episodes one new
one each week so in case you haven't
seen it yet you can click here for my
vixen episode one video and you can
click here for my Walking Dead Season
six preview break down the footage that
they showed such as stuff that talked
about like Jedi Morgan thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow